[Music]
not to be a downer on this evening but
there was some sad news recently thig
passed away what is your favorite memory
with big oh my gosh there's so many um
really hard to say I would say one of my
favorites is when big black was dressed
up like I don't know how to say like
like poop and there's a meme about it
actually where people go oh you think
I'm this now and it's a big black just
posing as poop so that was like one of
my favorite days filming even though I
didn't like my costume that much but
that was one of my favorite memory
there's so many though it's like I can
go on and on what do you want people to
remember about big black I want people
to definitely remember him for being the
fun-loving guy that he was but they
should also remember him for being a
great father because he was a great
father he lived in Dallas people I don't
think people know that you would fly out
here every week to film Fantasy Factory
and you know go back and forth for his
daughter and and he was just such a
great guy so I don't I won't talk about
what I'm actually gonna tear up and mess
up my makeup but yeah we really miss
them